بعد الشكاوى عده من شركات ومقاولين من
تاخر الصرف المستحقات والمستخسر بواسطه
المستخلصات الختامين وجه وزير الماليه
السعودي محمد الجدعان بصرف مستحق مستخلصه
عقود المشاريع السابقه والمتعثره لدى
المقاولين اضافه الى حال النزاعات بين
المتعاقدين والجهات الحكوميه حيث يتضمن
القرار حلول النظاميه لاعاده التوازن
المالي للعقود ومعالجه التحديات في صرف
المستخلصات الختاميه وايتاحه وسائل اضافيه
لبدائل حل النزاعات القائمه او المحتمله
بين الجهات الحكوميه والمتعاقدين
رياض ينضم الينا المدير التنفيذي للاداره
القانونيه في هيئه كفاءه الانفاق
والمشروعات الحكوميه ماجد التركي سيد مجد
اهلا وسهلا بك
معي في نشره الرابعه يعني
الان اذا كانت العقود هناك عقود واضح
وهناك اتفاقيات مستوفيه لكل الشروط
ومعتمده قانونيا ليش التاخر اولا في صرف
المستحقات وليش هناك حاجه اصلا الى توجيه
الوزير لتصرف هذه المستحقه
شكرا استاذ خالد
واهلكم واهتمامكم شكرا للعربيه
الحقيقه يعني هي قصه تحتاج الى ان نرويها
بشيء من الاقتضاء يمكنني ايضا اجمال هذا
القصه من خلال شرح غايات هذين
فما جاء فيهما هو للتغلب على التحديات
التعاقديه التي تحول دون الاستفاده من
الاعمال والاستثمارات الراسماليه الحكوميه
الجاهزه او التي قاربت على الجلوس
بالتالي تسريع اصول خدمه المواطنين وذلك
من خلال تعديل الاحكام وتعديل الاحكام صرف
المستحقات المقاولين وهذا اجابه على
سؤالكم لماذا همم لانه
غالبيه العقود ابرمت في كنف الامر السابقه
والاصلاحات الاخيره التي جاءت في نظام
المنافسات المشتريات الحكوميه اصبح من
المجدي ومن
اللازم ايضا
ان ان ان ان ايضا
تتمتع بها العقود التي قامت وابرمت في كن
في الانظمه السابقه وهو محول الامر مرسوم
الملكي الصادر بالنظام معالي الوزير بذلك
الامر الثاني من غايات القرار تعزيز قدره
المقاولين وسلسله التوريد التوريد
والامداد على انجاز مزيد مشاريع تنمويه
نحو التنامي فقدرات قطاع المقاولات وقطاع
سلسله التوريد والامداد من خلال تيسير
احكام اعاده التوازن المهني للعقود
وذلك ما جاء به النظام
العقود السابقه اللي كانت في الانظمه كان
فيها خلل
خلل الاجرائي خلل القانوني والعيش حتى
نقول الله انه يعاد النظر فيها
طبعا حالات التوازن المالي هنا ايضا اعاده
التوازن المالي للعقود هي احد الممثلات
النظاميه التي وردت في نظام منافسات
مشتريات الحكوميه وهي امور واحوال تعتريه
كل العقود
ولا يعني وجود
وجود التوازن او اختلال التوازن وجود
الخلل
الممكنات موجوده
الى معالي الوزير باصدارها طيب وشو حجمها
كم حجم هذه المستخلصات
المتاخره وكذلك المشاريع المتعثره
يعني هي هي هي
لدى هيئه كفاءه الانفاق حصر لها اولاد
الجهات الحكوميه اعداد لكنها بشكل ستستفيد
من القرار الصادر همم القرار الصادر من
معالي همم
حلول لاعاده التوازن لمده الزمنيه
المتاخره في في تحصيل هذه المستحقات ترى
احنا نسمع مشكله المقاولين من زمان يعني
من 10 او اكثر من 10 سنوات واكثر يعني هذه
الازمه مستمر
بحول الله وقوتين مع وجوه مع صدور هذه
القرارات
والاراده ستحلل كثير من المشكلات باذن
الله تعالى القرار يقول بانه حل النزاعات
بين المتعاقدين والجهات الحكوميه
وايضا اعاده التوازن العقود كما كما ذكرت
وشي مش طبيعه هذه النزاعات اذا ممكن
اشتمل القرار على معالجه ما قد يعتبر
العقود من ارتفاعات ارتفاع في الاسعار
طبعا ارتفاع الاسعار قد يكون ناجم عن
التضخم وقد يكون ناجم على القرارات وقد
يكون ناجم ايضا عن طبيعه السلع والخدمات
التي تتقلب اسعارها القرار اشتمل على
معالجه ما قدرت العقود والارتفاعات تحليل
الالتزامات
المتعاقدين الالتزامات مرهقه لذلك وضع
احكام بديل اهداف اجراءات وحكمه تمكن
الجهات الحكوميه
قبل الجهات القضائيه تمكن الجهات الحكوميه
للنظر مطالبات متعاقدين بتعديل الاسعار
واعاده توازن المالي
وقد تضمنت ايضا الاحكام
موضوع على مقدار التعويضات
وتوسع في نطاق ما يمكن التعويض عنه من
مواد وخدمات تاثرت بارتفاع الاسعار وذلك
تقديرا لمده الزمنيه التي ضلت بعض
المشاريع في دور التنفيذ طيب طبعا
هذا القرارات خلاص راح تنهي كل المشاكل كل
المشاكل التعثر المستحقات تعثر المشاريع
الاصلاحات متاحه ومازال مازال ال ال
مازالت
الامر موكول بيدمع للوزير لاصدار مزيد
قرارات لكن في تقدير
الفريق الذي يشكل واللجنه التي شكلت انها
قرارات تكفي لحل اكثر المشكلات
التي اقتنفت تعثر المشاريع او تاخر شكرا
جزيلا لكم من الرياضه المدير التنفيذي
لدار القانونيه في هيئه كفاءه الانفاق
والمشروعات الحكوميه ما اجدد التركي